hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my new Civil War Hulk video so just
careful for spoilers for Civil War Hulk
stuff so far all the heroes just got a
big teaser that the Hulk is going to
kill everyone in the Marvel Universe
hope kills the Marvel Universe Deadpool
style but like I said in my last video
Captain Marvel assumes that it's going
to be Bruce Banner whereas he is not the
Hulk right now in the recent spin-off
issue of Hulk like the Civil War tie-in
Hulk issue explains what Bruce Banner
has been doing with his time off
like when Amadeus Cho took all of his
gamma Bruce Banner effectively got a
vacation from being the Hulk so this
issue is like him going through the 12
stages of being an alcoholic like he
first he realizes oh my god I'm gamma
freak like maybe I can do whatever I
want I don't have to control myself cuz
I won't turn into the Hulk when things
go crazy so he has a very Superman -
Christopher Reeve moment where he gets
his ass beat at a diner like a douchebag
then he goes off tries to have some fun
gets lost in the desert and winds up
coming back around to his green car like
as much as he's gamma free he can't
leave the Hope behind there's a whole
lot of wonderful imagery like no matter
how far he travels the big green guy is
always going to be there then he goes
and has a little bit of fun gambling
remember card-counting not illegal and
he is a super genius so everybody around
him is still freaking out because they
don't really realize what's happened
they just see Bruce Banner and assume
that he's going to hook out so they're
like let's get the hell out of here Tony
Stark comes in and then that's when
Bruce Banner comes to the realization
like he has this very Tony Stark
alcoholic come-to-jesus moment where
everything kind of clicks in his brain
and he realizes that he was the monster
the whole time like a lot of times when
the Hulk would Hulk out and there'll be
all this collateral damage people would
say he's an Avenger he's a good person
the Hulk is the one that did this Bruce
Banner the man was innocent he's not in
control of himself but in this moment he
realizes that he was the monster of the
whole time that's why he can never leave
the hook behind because he himself is
the Hulk like the really angry persona
that just smashes things and just rages
out it's not the big green guy so it
gets a little meta but it's like that
alcoholics anonymous moment where he's
like I was the person doing those bad
things the whole time I can't keep
blaming the Hulk for all my mistakes so
what is this
have to do with Hulk killing the Marvel
Universe well there's a couple things
going on one we don't fully understand
how Ulysses visions work Tony Stark's
research was kind of cut short so he
still has absolutely no idea what's
going on inside and said when a vision
is occurring - maybe they're being
misinterpreted maybe we're not actually
seeing the future and three how can
there be two Hulk's at the same time if
Amadeus Cho absorbed all of Bruce's
gamma and they basically at the end of
the issue they say you're 100% gamma
free so supposedly a Marvel editor
revealed that this mystery Hulk like who
the hell is killing everyone really is
Bruce Banner but there are so many hoops
that you have to jump through to get to
that like one you have to explain how
Bruce Banner can become the Hulk again
if he doesn't have any gamma in them
does he take all of his gamma back from
Amadeus Cho how does that even work and
what is it that leads to him hooking out
on everyone because when the Hulk
becomes the Hulk he still has some brain
function like there are several
different versions in the comics of the
Bruce Banner Hulk there's the really
chatty Hulk the one that has the mind of
Bruce Banner in the body of the Hulk
that's really what you want you want the
mind of this genius Avenger in this
indestructible super strong body most of
the time when you think of the Hulk
though you don't think of this really
smart version of the Hulk you think of
the primate Hulk like the most basic of
emotions just rage hunger smash if smash
could be an emotion let me know in the
comments let's assume for the sake of
argument that Bruce Banner becomes the
Hulk again how do you think that happens
do you think he's gonna take his gamma
back from Amadeus Cho
so Amadeus Cho won't be the Hulk anymore
where do you think he'll be irradiated
again so you'll have to Holtz so you can
get Hulk vs. Hulk or is it gonna be some
weird meta thing where he's like I've
been The Hulk the whole time the gamma
didn't turn me into the Hulk I've always
been the hole and he just magically
Hulk's out that's one of those the power
was within you the whole time twist
which at this point are kind of
so I'm assuming that he gets irradiated
or he takes his gamma back from Amadeus
Cho but do you remember during Planet
Hulk World War Hulk when he's getting
ready to kill everyone and then all of a
sudden Amadeus Cho walks up and he
starts to calm down so even if this
isn't going to be a complete reversal of
that I'm expecting a few Easter eggs
because usually it's been aa madea's Cho
that helps Bruce Banner out in times of
great need so now
I wonder if it's gonna be Bruce Banner
helping Amadeus Cho out if something
really terrible happens to him but if
you haven't been reading all the Civil
War tie-ins you don't absolutely have to
they just explain things and great
detail like you get this Hulk Ferris
Bueller's Day Off moment where he's just
out having fun just like oh my god I'm
free oh wait no no I'm not so in related
comic-book news they just released the
new issue of flash rebirth number one so
I'll be doing a video for that this
weekend but I'll also be at VidCon so
I'll try to post videos as much as
possible so updates on Twitter and
Facebook for all that stuff be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if you
do see me at VidCon be sure to say hi
I'll be I'll tell people when I get down
there I'm not quite a big con yet what
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn more about
what's going on with Marvel's Civil War
and you can click here to learn more
about what's going on with DC's rebirth
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you